[Music]
in poor baby news submitted by CID
Laluna the husband of a Teen Mom star is
being investigated after killing his
wife's dog hmm which one I know the teen
moms oh yeah I was addicted that show
really and you love TV huh I loved she
like yes many exactly thank you he likes
people's misery shitty reality TV is
some of the best [ __ ] ever made
did you see the the Jersey short one
they just came out the reunion no no
it's Heidi and yeah Benny or whatever Oh
something about love yeah yeah
so they it's basically like the flavor
love or like The Bachelor or whatever
they live in one household they all
compete for them their love it's [ __ ]
fun they compete for those dudes love
that's ty still think the bachelor was
just two guys now yeah that's really
good me and wait and hope and Oh Paulie
yeah it's like blue-collar bachelor
exactly ha that's what makes it even
better
that's really funny those guys are
really entertaining too when they're
together no amazing I would watch that
show oh it's like that like my strange
addiction yeah like people who [ __ ] cars
and stuff I eat napkins napkins eaten
couches eaten all times this is ot mom
yeah so this is about Jenelle Evans oh
my God look at that guy that's a very
detailed photo oh my god I think I know
who that is he looks like a boy but a
man she's been seeing mom since the
first season okay yeah he looks like a
boy like a man boy yes my god it's the
way he's holding her - it's like the air
- like the old Bieber cut yeah it's like
he could be a lumberjack but a pop
singer yeah so here's their family
see not now he looks like a like a
looks like a [ __ ] in one of the duck
guys yeah the dynasty she's so cute what
happened and then this is Janelle's dog
thanks French bulldogs they're crazy
yeah French bulldogs are nuts so it
seems like this guy her husband the one
in the picture
her husband okay yeah his name is David
he is under investigation for suspected
animal cruelty to the French Bulldog
yeah we do kick a soccer ball so this
dog allegedly but I mean there's video
proof bit this two-year-old daughter
history year-old daughter in the face oh
and then I would have thrown that dog
over there seeing what he did is do the
dog in the dryer in the dryer yeah cuz
you know tumbles rounds it kind of
tortures him why you do so the dog
nipped at the little baby girl so then
he sprung up grab the dog by the throat
and slammed it on the ground and then he
began beating the dog inside the house
didn't get in the throat and throwing
the French Bulldog into a kitchen table
sure the dog into the kitchen table and
there's video but no none of that
sniffing so then as the dog was wailing
oh he he just kept raining down punches
on his head and then everyone in the
house was too terrified to stop it oh my
god umm so then he picked up the
apparently lifeless dog Oh threw it out
the front door and then he returned back
inside the house grabbed a pistol and a
shotgun and then returned outside people
what is going on this wall has issues
the dog was shot to death so when he
returned home his clothes were covered
that's his dog and his clothes were
covered in blood
da and I'm saying that the daughter was
at home at the time or sorry the wife
was at home at the time as well
that's the dog his daughter Nick [ __ ]
this guy's yeah Jesus posted a video of
the dog nipping at the daughter let me
see how bad this is I'm wondering if
that would trigger like this killer
instinct when your child is that deep
[ __ ]
no this is exactly this guy's a small
dick look what happen is you need to
know what your dog's temperament is
right if you know that like if you pull
that a dog too much and stuff like I've
had fun who's docile and [ __ ] sweet
as [ __ ] Tyko goes and he like pokes her
eye and stuff and shoka like and then
she goes out she's like trying to like
defend herself she goes out and then she
like wants to nip at him but she'll stop
herself but I'm not gonna beat her if
she ever gets to him cuz I'm like [ __ ] I
should have been watching tight because
at the end of the day she has sweet as
she is and she doesn't bite you and do
anything she's still an animal so for me
to get pissed at her it's like not it's
my fault that I wasn't and I wasn't
watching my own child that's [ __ ]
that's a lot of thinking though I'm
talking in terms of yeah instinct so
like immediately let's say at the dog
park right and it's not your dog but
they're your kids just hanging out and
then BOOM a dog by it happens I could
picture myself going over there and in
like cracking that dog's neck or
something immediately just you know I'm
saying like that's what he's saying
you're not thinking at all that homeless
animal it's not help like I'm thinking
like well this is a French Bulldog right
you could literally just throw it I did
this with meatloaf when he was trying to
eat one of Gina's friends dog and I'm
not thinking all I'm thinking his holy
[ __ ] German Shepherd is pretty big
he's like 100 pound German Shepherd and
he's trying to kill this dog he has a
dog by the neck and I'm just punching
him in the face trying to and he's my
own dog trying to get him to let go and
I'm like Oh different cuz he was like on
him yeah yeah what's the threat was
eliminated you don't know no I don't
yeah so I think that's what that's the
part that makes him a [ __ ] the dog nips
or even stirred on latches on you grab
the dog but technically your dog is also
your family member so once the threat is
eliminated okay cool yeah when he took
the dog out and slam
on the ground and started wailing on him
and then the dogs likeness he still
walks in like 20-ish
that's a lot of like Gio you were trying
to harm your dog you're trying to you're
trying to dissolve a situation yes I was
trying to inflict some sort of like
snapping him out of it or trying to save
another dog's life yeah it's open it and
then I realized like me hitting him is
making it worse because now he's
becoming more aggressive would you
tickle him you're supposed to choke him
no so what is happening I got him from
his hind legs and because he's off
balance he was like all [ __ ] and that's
what made him let go wouldn't win a dog
you're supposed to choke the dog if the
dog yeah where is oh I couldn't do it so
so basically if you have a collar yes
because people it like they bite they
hold on and things like that there's a
way where you pull upwards so you lift
it up by its neck and then the jaw will
because it's not gonna work that way
yeah yeah no this wasn't happening cuz
it didn't matter how much I lifted he
was still holding on to the dog bag and
he was like just chopping I'm like oh my
god it was it was crazy
luckily a dog was ok with yeah the dog
left so this is a video clip that he
posted to kind of justify why he did
what he did in jail [ __ ] him
oh well they're investigating you should
go yeah [ __ ] this guy dude this guy is a
[ __ ] man I did do this in front of your
daughter
I know exactly and so pretty crazy this
is what he said I don't give a damn what
animal bites my baby on the face whether
it be your dog or mine a dog is a dog
and I don't put up with that [ __ ] at all
but it's a French Bulldog bro tough guy
I'm all about protecting my family and
my life's mission some people are worth
killing or dying for and my family means
that much tomorrow you can treat me all
you want
this fool acts like it was a [ __ ]
German Shepherd but this isn't the first
time the Bulldog Lee aggressively the
only person that can judge whether or
not an animal is a danger to my child is
me ok this is a video that's like it was
a bear these ladies willing to die for
his family say you
have to die for anything you ready news
oh dude that was nothing Rosen awesome I
thought it was a mauling oh no do it he
went oh no dude she's holding a little
parakeet the parakeet bites her finger
and he [ __ ] goes get a baseball bat
and then he's like I hate this guy I
always will protect my family come at me
like a [ __ ] little [ __ ] point dude
it was a [ __ ] B it's like it's not
even a full-grown French Bulldog you
look like a puppy still and the dog
didn't even hold on it was just like
like I'm getting cornered and I feel
uncomfortable he knew that this dog had
that [ __ ] cuz I've seen maulings like
straight cuz he goes oh baby no like he
knew that was about to happen these are
the people who always go like I gotta
teach you a family on my chest like my
family comes first always and like
somebody like like drugs like drives her
car bumper into their their family
members car and they go [ __ ] wail on
him through the window and I think he's
the one that if they'd hit the bumper
and he sees that it's another man he's
like it's cool bro it's cool like you
that [ __ ] that's just a toy it's called
a bumper for a reason yep was a woman
he's probably like what the [ __ ] man
those guys they go extra Target when
they don't fight back so they're saying
that now he is currently seeking
treatment for his anger management issue
and then they're also reporting that
those close to the family have also
reported reportedly contacted Child
Protective Services about getting him
removed from the home that shares with
Jenelle and the three turtle children
I agree has ever hit the children though
I don't know so that's over the top yeah
that's true yeah that's pretty crazy
it's always the it's always a [ __ ]
looking guys to me
there has been suspected violence before
because Janelle called 9-1-1 in October
to report that her husband pinned her to
the ground and drunkenly assaulted her
but then later called the incident a
misunderstanding
oh come on ladies she told her mr.
standing yeah so then I that photo that
I showed you guys of her in the dog she
she posted that and captioned it that
she was crying every day and that she's
speechless she's like you were my
sidekick in you the moment I felt bad I
would cuddle with me you still had a lot
to learn and a lot to grow from your
lessons every day I wake up you're not
here when I come home you're not here
when I go to bed you're not here you're
gone forever and there's no coming back
in the worst way possible t when you own
an animal it's on you dude you own a
[ __ ] animal you don't own a perfect
[ __ ] thing that knows exactly what
right and wrong as you own an animal and
that wasn't even a ball her dog no I
know but that's what I'm saying you'd
say you probably already wanted a dog
dead like it was annoying him he kept
like [ __ ] I can't wait to that and then
like he just snapped
I read in one of these articles that
believe that this was a premeditated oh
I keep planned it all out cuz he's been
wanting the dog like Gio just said he
was waiting for the ship Gordon is
waiting for an opportunity like this
yeah that's weird that he's recording at
that moment yeah that's really weird
oh god I hate this guy mm-hmm I think he
should get beat to death and then like
at the last minute shot up but then kept
alive do I normally the guy who's like
cool unusual punishment I'm like I'm
with you on this one dude yeah I can
[ __ ] with animals it's crazy to me
especially cuz little animal it's a it's
it's a puppy yeah like that's like
[ __ ] with children to me it's the
same thing it's like it's like you just
murdered him three-year-old yeah so
Jenelle has not been fired from a Teen
Mom because of this whole incident way
she has yeah she is no longer gonna show
just cuz a bad PR yeah it just painted
the brand yeah so they ended that
relationship with her and with the guy
they're saying that they ended a
relationship with David over a year ago
Oh cuz he's a [ __ ] yeah and then now
they ended it with her she also said
like they were having marital problems
all this obviously but then she also she
commented saying that now she's trying
to move forward with her family and she
wants to mend her her marriage so she's
gonna continue to try to work that thing
good luck girl
anyone who beats the [ __ ] out of a puppy
is just [ __ ] weird dude if you could
beat the [ __ ] out of a puppy you could
be [ __ ] out of anything yeah nah I guess
so yeah if you have the wherewithal to
do that [ __ ] like mentally and [ __ ] I
don't think you want to a pimple like
Gio said he's probably one of those guys
it's like those you know guys that beat
up girls but they can't beat up guys
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]